I want to use this video to try to get a
better intuition for futures curves and
in particular to understand that the
futures curves shows a snapshot in time
of the different market prices for the
essentially the delivery price at
different future dates so what when I
say that I know those kind of confusing
statement and this futures curve right
over here when you have a delivery date
that's zero months from now that's
essentially today that's the market
price that is the actual market price of
that commodity in this example the
commodity is silver so if you were to go
out and buy silver today it would cost
you roughly thirty two dollars let me
say that this is per ounce it would cost
you thirty two dollars per ounce when I
say one out here this is one month in
the future I'm not talking about the
price I'm not talking about the spot
price of silver in a month I'm talking
about the price today in the market if
you were to agree to buy or sell silver
in a month the futures price for a
delivery one month out that's what that
is right now so I want to make it very
clear this is not showing you how the
spot price of silver will move over the
next eight months it's telling you today
if you wanted to transact in silver
right now you would transact at $32 an
ounce if today you agree to transact in
silver a month from now you would
transact you would buy or sell it looks
at around thirty three dollars an ounce
if today you were to agree to buy or
sell silver four months from now you
would do it at $35 an ounce if today I
don't want to be redundant but if today
you were to agree to buy or sell silver
eight months from now and you were to
lock in the price you would lock in a
price it looks at like about I don't
know thirty six dollars an ounce so this
is really a snapshot in time and if for
example let's say tomorrow the price of
silver there's this huge silver shortage
or people realize a new application for
silver that could change the world then
when you would have tomorrow is that
this whole curve would probably shift up
the whole curve would shift up something
like that so no matter when you decide
to actually transact in the silver it'll
actually get more expensive but I want
to make it very clear that this is just
a snapshot in time and to better
understand that
I've also drawn over here how the prices
can move it over time and I've drawn
different durations so in purple right
over here I've drawn the spot price so
this is a spot price today and over here
this is a spot price today but then I've
shown how it changes in time so this is
kind of closer to a traditional stock
chart this just tells us that look
that's not the spot price started at $32
and went up a little bit went down a
little bit it kind of just goes up and
down oscillates a bit over the next
eight months so this is actual movement
over time this is a snapshot of delivery
dates at some point in the future so the
spot price just moves around and let's
just take this green contract right over
here so we start on the first day the
green contract if you agree to transact
in silver four months from now you're
agreeing to transact at about thirty
four dollars so that's where you would
transact right now that that four month
out contract but as you move beautiful
as you move more and more forward in
time you're getting closer and closer to
that delivery date if you move one month
into the future now that contract is
only going to be three months out you
move two months in the future now that
contract is only two months out all the
way until if you move four months out
this contract will now be essentially
the spot price because you're now
agreeing to transact now that'll happen
four months from now but you'll now be
agreeing to transact at that moment and
so at that moment that price should be
the same as a spot price so you'll have
this converging with the spot price and
the same thing for the eight month out
contract it couldn't it should converge
over the next eight months